find the probability of flipping exactly
two heads on three coins so to figure
out this probability a good place to
start is just to think about all of the
different possible ways that we can flip
three coins so we could get we could get
all tails tails tails tails we could get
tails tails heads we could get tails
heads tails we could get tails heads
heads we could get heads tails tails we
could get heads tails heads we could get
heads heads tails and then we could get
all heads and we could get all heads
over here so they are one two three four
five six seven eight possible outcomes
eight possible outcomes outcomes now how
many of the outcomes involve flipping
exactly exactly two heads let's see
that's all tails it's one hand one hand
this has two heads right there two heads
it's one head this is two heads right
over there then this is two heads right
over here and then this is three heads
so that doesn't count so there are three
three outcomes three outcomes where we
with exactly with exactly exactly
exactly two heads
so we spelled heads properly two heads
so the probability the probability of
flipping of exactly exactly two heads in
the word exactly is important because if
you didn't say exactly then maybe three
heads will you flip two heads so we have
to say exactly two heads so you don't so
you you don't include the situation
where you get three heads so the
probability of flipping exactly two
heads is equal to the three outcomes
with two heads divided by the eight
possible outcomes or 3/8 so it is equal
to 3/8 and we are done